week Nevada Governor Joe Lombardo faces
an Ethics Hearing in a 1.7 million
dollar fine the case will be heard on
Tuesday it's inner centers around these
campaign ads during the gubernatorial
race the executive director of the
ethics commission says it was a
violation for Lombardo to where his
Clark County sheriff badge and uniform
in the ads in all they counted up to 68
willful and serious violations also
included in the potential penalty
Accenture and the installation of an
ethic ethics officer in the governor's
office the fine would be the largest in
State history the current record is just
tens of thousands of dollars we're
talking 1.6 million dollars here
Governor Lombardo's attorney compared to
the Fine to swatting a fly with
sledgehammers we spoke with Democrat and
election attorney Bradley Schrager
let's be clear about sort of where we
are in the in the in the procedure as
well the commission itself hasn't done
anything
um this is akin to
in a criminal context a prosecutor
saying
I find you to or I consider you to have
committed violations and here's the
sentence that I'm asking for the
commission is free to accept that to
increase it or to decrease it and it's
at its at its uh at its complete
discretion so you know the ethics
commission hasn't done anything the
essentially the executive director and
his legal staff has asked for that given
the severity of the of the issues should
it be that high clearly under law it is
it is two things it is both allowed to
be this high
even if it seems to be incredibly steep
as you say but at the same time this is
a this is a pattern of abuse and
disregard of Ethics standards in Nevada
that is itself
more or less unprecedented so we don't
know yet how the commission's going to
come down on this
what is ethically wrong about someone
who at the time was an elected Sheriff
using
or
presenting the fact that he has this
position while running for a different
position yeah well you know there's
certainly no no hiding the fact that
that he was Sheriff when he was running
for it right it's for pretty high
profile position but being the sheriff
uh or being a military man being being
any of those things it's
um is different in a democracy than it
is being a realtor or some woman who
works in a paint store right it's a it's
a it's a different uh you were invested
with certain powers and Authority now
that the ethics code says you cannot use
not just a badge or a gun or your or
your Sheriff's uniform you cannot use
the trappings of your office to gain
something worth value to you like
another office you also can't use public
property to run for office so those are
the cores is that the commission has
long held that the things that go along
with being Sheriff your badge your uh
uniform those kinds of things are the
trappings of office that you can't use
to run for further office so you know
whether or not it's inherently wrong for
you to do that that's long been the law
and everyone knows it as did Sheriff
Lombardo then Sheriff Lombardo the
entire time that he was running for
governor and doing these things this is
just a recommendation though at the end
of the day do you envision the governor
or his office or his campaign funding
1.6 million dollars or whatever it might
be actually being the penalty you know
just like when you know when a
prosecutor goes in and asks for the
maximum sentence or for sentences to run
consecutively that's oftentimes a
reflection of how seriously the
prosecutor is taking the matter and
trying to send signals to the court or
in this instance the commission of how
uh uh how serious these violations were
I presume that like in the courtroom
context this will be resolved at a
slightly lower level but there's no way
to let them off I mean not only does he
stipulate to the fact that he did these
things it's very clear that he knew
these things were unlawful so it's not
as if you can get away with not uh you
know not having a penalty at all that's
that's clearly not going to happen and
as far as the sort of hammer and
reference you know let's remember that
this is the sheriff who you know the
phrase Zero Tolerance was dripping from
his lips not just when he was running
for governor uh but but but as sheriff
for many years so there's zero tolerance
for undocumented immigration zero
tolerance for misdemeanor crime zero
tolerance for retail theft zero
tolerance for everything but apparently
a very high tolerance for knowing
violations of law so I don't think you
get to call yourself the ant in this
analogy uh when you're when you know
when your conduct is in this you know
area
now we did reach out to the governor's
attorney and some of his campaign team
for this story for some comment neither
returned our calls the hearing is on
Tuesday up in Reno